to a story that president biden is aware
of we are learning more about a stunning
assassination attempt against the prime
minister of iraq that could show the
future of terrorism someone flew at
least two armed drones into his home
yesterday but he escaped with only a
small cut iraq security forces believe a
militia backed by iran is responsible
mts taeb has been following this story
mts good morning
nate good morning yes we have a very
intense situation on the ground in
baghdad right now take a look at this
this is just outside the prime
minister's residence where at least six
members of his security detail were
injured in that drone attack now in an
address to the nation shortly after the
strike mustafa academy said quote drone
attacks do not build homelands and do
not build a future now reports just
coming in at this very moment suggest
iranian-made drones and explosives were
used in this attack and while no group
has claimed responsibility it comes at a
time of deadly protests over the weekend
following disputed elections which saw
parties aligned with iranian-backed
militias lose two-thirds of their seats
in parliament as far as we know never
has a drone been used to target the head
of state of any country and this strike
sets an alarming precedent for a
technology that has gone from being
advanced weaponry in a military's
arsenal to being commercially available
and the concern now is that this brazen
assassination attempt will only trigger
more violence tony
very scary to see use of this technology
spread this way mts taeyab in london for
us mts thank you very much